foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones and
House of the dragon video in this video
I want to go over what really happened
when vamon valerion died in George R
Martin's novel Fire and Blood although
House of the Dragon is adapting what
happened in Fire and Blood they are
still leaving out certain things from
the original story as you all know in
House of the Dragon we saw vamon
valerion fight for the rights of his
ancestral home of driftmark after
learning his brother Lord Corliss
valerion suffered a grave injury during
the battle in the stepstones he felt the
driftmark along with the Driftwood
Throne should go to him since his
brother no longer had any legitimate
male heirs Not only was Lenor valerion
thought to be dead but he knew renyra's
Sons were bastards as you saw in House
of the Dragon after insulting rhaenyra
and her sons in front of everyone in the
Great Hall Damon Targaryen sliced off
his damn head with his Valyrian steel
sword Dark sister now this is sort of
what did happen in George R Martin's
novel Fire and Blood however there are
some mine and major differences as well
I want to show you how it was written by
George RR Martin because I think some of
you will like his version also roughly
three years before the start of the
dance of the Dragons the sea snake Lord
Corliss valerion suddenly became very
sick with a fever he was not injured in
battle like we heard in the show as he
laid in his bed surrounded by maesters
the issue arose as to who should succeed
him as the master of driftmark should
the sickness take his life since his son
and daughter were dead by law his lands
and titles should go to his grandson
jacaris but since Jace might have
ascended the Iron Throne after his
mother rhaenyra urged her good father to
name instead her second son lucaries now
Lord Corliss valerion also had half a
dozen nephews however the eldest of them
surveymon valerion did fight over his
inheritance because he thought driftmark
should go to him on the grounds that
raniera's Sons were bastards sired by
Sir Harwin after hearing about this
rhaenyra was not slow in answering this
accusation
she had Damon Targaryen see surveymon
and have his head removed then she fed
his dead body to her Dragon Cyrax
slicing off his head wasn't enough she
even wanted his dead body given to her
dragon as a little snack even this did
not end the matter however sir vamon's
younger brothers fled the King's Landing
with his wife and sons there to cry for
justice and set their own rights before
the king viserys had grown extremely fat
and read of face and scarce had the
strength to mount the steps to the Iron
Throne instead his grace heard them out
in a Stony silence then ordered every
one of their tongues to be removed you
were warned he declared as they were
being dragged away I will hear no more
of these lies so as you can see it was
written somewhat differently in the
novel The Sea Snake wasn't injured in
battle there wasn't this big dramatic
scene in the Great Hall of the red keep
either and we did not get that amazing
moment with visares now that is one
major addition I did love why watching
viserys enter the Great Hall in seeing
Damon help him onto the throne before he
stood up for his daughter was an amazing
way to do the scene however there is one
thing I wish they did add now maybe it
does sound a little dark but I wish we
did see renero feed his dead body to her
Dragon rather than only seeing rainey's
look over as the maesters worked on him
with that being said I do think the show
enhanced what George R Martin had
written in Fire and Blood he only had a
few lines that described what happened
whereas the show had this amazing moment
that involved nearly every main
character something that was basically a
throwaway line was brought to life in
such a great way if you ask me viserys
was obviously the standout from the
scene but I even love the Waymon
delivered his lines you could actually
feel the Venom in each of his insults
making his death even more satisfying
thankfully they did show this beheading
since we did not get to see Damon
deliver that fatal blow to the crab
feeder now all I need to see is the
dragons have some fun as well and I
think we will get to see that in this
final episode of the season on this
Sunday let me know what all of you think
down below as always I want to thank all
of you for watching the video I hope all
of you have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye
dragon's eggs Daenerys
from the shadowlands Beyond a shy
the ages have turned them to Stone but
they will always be beautiful
the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over
until we forget that it's a lie
in House of the dragon's most recent
episode we saw Damon Targaryen find
cyrax's three dragon eggs while on
Dragonstone ever since fans saw this
scene in episode 8 of House of the
Dragon they had been wondering if Damon
actually found dany's three dragon eggs
drogon rhaegal and viserion not only
were they the exact same amount of eggs
Danny was gifted in season 1 of Game of
Thrones but they also looked exactly the
same as well as we all know drogon's egg
was black and red while rhaegar's egg
was green and viserions was a golden
yellow during a behind-the-scenes shot
from House of the Dragon we do see the
dragon eggs Damon found from Cyrax or
blackish red green and golden yellow it
would be very interesting if these were
in fact the eggs Daenerys eventually
received from illyrio now in George R
Martin's novel Fire and Blood we may
have already found out where dany's
dragon eggs are actually from in season
1 of Game of Thrones when Dany is given
the dragon eggs we heard illyrio say
they were from the shadowlands Beyond
shy but how did they actually get there
well in Fire and Blood we hear of
someone named Elisa farman who was said
to be in love with Reina Targaryen now
during the year of 54 AC Elisa
discreetly stole three dragon eggs from
dragonstone's hatcheries before sailing
off to essos where she would later sell
the eggs for a ship those three dragon
eggs were from the dragon dream fire who
we have already met in House of the
Dragon we saw dream fire during a scene
when aemon Targaryen went looking for a
dragon to mount of his own now if you
did notice in that scene dream fire did
look exactly like Danny's dragons and
that does make a lot of sense because
according to George R Martin's novel
Fire and Blood dream fire is the mother
of drogon rhaegal and viserion so if we
are to believe what is written in Fire
and Blood then dany's dragon eggs were
stolen from Dragonstone over 75 years
before the events in House of the Dragon
when we see Damon find those three
dragon eggs on Dragonstone dany's a egg
should have already been over ernestos
for many decades now that story was
written in Fire and Blood but that
doesn't mean House of the dragon's
writers won't do something different the
three dragon eggs found by Damon very
well could end up being the same eggs
Danny gets in season one of Game of
Thrones you never know the writers of
House of the Dragon might decide they
want to have dany's dragon eggs be from
Cyrax instead of dreamfire as you all
know that would give dany's dragons an
even greater connection to this show
either way we have already met the
mother of drogon rhaegal and viserion
whether it's dream fire or Cyrax I
happen to believe what's written in Fire
and Blood I think the mother of Danny's
dragon eggs is dreamfire considering how
much he actually looks just like drogon
rhaegar and viserion therefore I think
dany's dragon eggs were already gone
from Dragonstone well before Damon finds
the three eggs in the last episode of
House of the Dragon that's what I think
but I would like to hear all of your
thoughts as well let me know what you
think down below as always I want to
thank all of of you for watching this
video I hope all of you have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
foreign